si es que las dos partes tanto los
abogados del trump como el gobierno
federal dieron el visto bueno para que
se publicara esta orden de búsqueda esta
orden de allanamiento que buscaba pues
encontrar estos documentos que el ex
presidente don otro se había llevado de
la casa blanca a su residencia en mar al
agua en la florida y no había querido
devolver a pesar de los continuos
pedidos que le había hecho él en los
archivos nacionales en eeuu para que
devolviera esta información confidencial
fueron 20 cajas precisamente que estaba
pidiendo archivos nacionales y que por
ende entonces llevó a que los agentes
del fbi allanaron la residencia del ex
presidente y sacaran esta información
que pues el pedido precisamente mostrado
a que te que tenía información
confidencial de la más alta
confidencialidad
el presidente del ex presidente de
donald trump también había archivos con
fotos había también material sobre el
presidente de francia y otros documentos
también secretos que terminaron sacando
los agentes del fbi entre los crímenes
que estaría cometiendo el ex presidente
de donald trump al quedarse con esta
información por un lado es precisamente
haberse haber sacado información
confidencial de la casa blanca' haber
destruido obstruido la investigación que
estaba llevando a cabo el fbi y no haber
cumplido con el pedido de archivos
nacionales y precisamente pues violar el
acta de espionaje es decir haberse
quedado con información de seguridad
nacional de eeuu que terceros habían
podido acceder y esto preocupa mucho
porque precisamente le veo y está
preguntándose quién tiene esta
información y a quien se le compartió
que reacciones a cristóbal hasta el
momento alrededor de los hechos
bastante reacciones por parte de los
demócratas y de los republicanos los
republicanos llevan ya varios días
reaccionando al respecto diciendo que
esto es una cacería de brujas que es una
farsa el propio expresidente de trump
reaccionó hoy con dos comunicados el
primero diciendo que esto era
precisamente una cacería de brujas que
era un seguimiento que le estaba
haciendo a él el fbi y el gobierno de
joe bai ling y en un segundo comunicado
diciendo que el ex presidente barack
obama también se llevó información
confidencial e información nuclear que
es lo que el waterpolo se está
reportando tiene el ex presidente donald
trump o tenía en su mansión de mar al
lago lo que es curioso es que él el
director en este momento del fbi
christopher way fue nombrado por el
propio expresidente donald trump y pues
ya salió también archivos nacionales a
contradecir este segundo comunicado de
don otros diciendo que obama barack
obama no tiene en su poder ninguna
información confidencial